and this is the fit, I am gonna do a
Full spin, a full spin
Damn Mom! 50 who?
50 who?
Ok so my dad just shut my phone off!
Can you believe it?
I'm 25 and have to pay for my own phone?
Anyways
I am at Massage Envy to get my mom
a lil gift card
Hello   Hi
I wanted to get something for my mom for Christmas
She says that I stress her out
So I was like
Perfect place, yeah perfect place
The audacity of this man
Don't get me wrong he is mad right now
because when I moved to England
I may or may not have
ran up my international bills
because it took me a while to figure out how to get a phone in England
Now I have no phone
I am going around phoneless!
Phoneless! Now the other problem
With not having a cell phone
is I am a Millenial
Barely, I am like the youngest Millenial. I grew up
On GPS
I don't know how to get anywhere!
Like where am I? I know I grew up here
Dad I am sorry!
I am sorry!   I won't use it again!
Just turn on my phone!!
I took a turn, uhm
Hopefully, this path leads me to home
I just wanna get home!  Oh my god, do I have sauce on my face?
Okay, I had Chipotle guys,
Okay, sue me! Sue me!
Let's just talk about top 5 dumbest things I have ever done
There is literally a GPS in the car
oh my god I see my dad I am about to confront him
Dad!
Did you turn off my phone?
Wait, my phone just shut off!
Oh, I thought it was you
So, it turns out
It turns out
He did shut off my phone
What, so why is it off?
Come on, Verizon!
Today, we are going to Christmas mass
and this is the fit, I am going
to do a full spin
Damn Mom!
Fifty Who?
Are you my Mom or my Sister?
okay and then we got Amelia, you look so pretty
Well okay, this is what you do. You post a
thirst trap right? and then guys will Dm you
and be like "hey"
and then you can pick
You guys had yearbook photos?
We have Instagram
Amelia, you look so pretty
This is our Christmas tree
and look at that tree right there!
I want them to look like mustard.
Dad you look so handsome!
Oh my God!
Adam, so what were you supposed to wear tonight?
I don't know!
That was what my mom asked him to wear
Eva!  Dang! Stop!
I love you!
The feeling is not mutual.
You are one of my favorite people in the family.
You might even be number one if you loved me back.
Let's see....there would be probably Amelia
No, no, Greg
Greg? You barely see Greg? Mary..
That's the point. Ok. and then
Mary and then I guess
Amelia and then Chas and
what? Am I last? and then Austin
Am I
and then, yeah and then
probably you and then Gabrielle
Okay, so I am second to last?
I mean....I will take it.
Aw! You look so cute!
Hug ! Hug!
Alright, me and Gabrielle made it to Mass. We are like
Fashionably late you would say
Sorry about that, that is my fault. Fashionably
uhm, I hate Catholic mass. It is so boring. I do not care.
Mom, mom how was communion? Stop!
What did you think of mass?
If you had to pick one Davis to marry?
Who would it be?
Probably me. Including the boys. You have to keep
the boys in it like probably
Oliver
Another family tradition we have in secret santa
so there is the answer card. So what we do
Everybody gets assigned a secret santa
and uhm they have
to guess
whose it was and then whoever wins
gets a cash prize. This year's cash prize
was $200
so we take very
seriously secret santa
you are not supposed to ask people who they had
I did not ask, I was told!
Ooo! I can't really open it.
That is what it looks like! She is only 19!
Okay, you have to throw one of us off a building?
Try to kill somebody in the family?
It depends on the day
Some days it would be Adam. Other days
it would probably be Eva in my younger days
in my younger days
Adam and Eva
Now?
Probably Adam.
You said Starbies?
I can't enjoy a nice beverage?? It's Starbucks!
Sorry it's quicker than Starbucks!
I was like you better not say me.
No, honestly I
have never thought about throwing anybody off a building
besides Adam and Eva
If they are cute, I am guessing Gabrielle.
If they are not, I am guessing someone else.
What did I get you? You got me a massage.
Gift card. Do you know why I got it
for you? No I don't. Because you said I
stress you out.
It will be well used.
What could it be?
It is empty!
Oh, wow!
He got exactly what I asked for.
I asked her who she had and she said Chas
But I was like no! I lied
Look it, I lied!
I knew you didn't have Chas because
Eva told me
she had Chas. That is why I put it for Eva because
I was like she acted weird when I said
that so she knows who has it.
and I was like Gabrielle
It is
not Gabrielle
because I asked Gabrielle so I knew it was Eva. But I still lost!!!
Loser!!
So today is Christmas morning
and I am waiting on my siblings to get up
because
they are literally
still asleep
We have this many presents.
and this is for
I don't want to say all 10 of us cause
not everyone comes to Christmas
but there is like 7 of us here?
Christmas morning, my mom cooks us food
and it's ok
I guess
This is my spatula knife
I  have gained 6 pounds in a week from my moms cooking.
oh god, what is on my face
I make smoothies, so you could say I carry the bulk of the family load
So one of our family traditions is making
these Christmas cookies
so it was my great grandmas recipe
so it is the only Christmas cookie we have ever made.
it starts with dough
and then you turn them into cookies
they are all rolled sugar cookies little =
Christmas trees and then
we get together with friends
and we decorate them
and another Christmas tradition
is over here
these are my advent candles
so
every single day from the start of advent
they are lit the whole day
How? How did I do that
ok. 6 lbs.
I gained 6 lbs in a week from my moms cooking
So another Christmas tradition
is that
we don't ever put
the tags on
the presents and so
everybody has to figure out what presents are theres
So Everybody has their own kind of wrapping paper
I am kind of like totally into wrapping
so in case you are wondering
I make it an art form and
then everybody this is the little directory
and so the kids
have to do a scavenger hunt to figure out
which
color is theirs
It was so good though
So good. This started because
We didn't have a lot of money a few years ago
and wanted to make Christmas
last longer so we tortured
them. So it that the answers?
I have it on video?
They say get you a girl that cooks right?  Wrong.
Wrong! You are going to get fat.
Fat!
Another tradition is
over here. There
is an ornament
That has everybody's names on it
and it is, it says 2021
but there is so many heads you can't even
see what it is
and this year we have Morgan
She is new! So and we
would like Melissa right here but Austin
has not figured out how to
put a ring on it.
so, these are our Christmas stockings
Another tradition
we have are these nutcrackers
So for 2021
These are the nutcrackers that everybody got
I always try to find a nutcracker
that kind of represents them
this is Hannah
and she is in England right now and
this is probably more scottish than English
but that kind of looks
sort of like you
and we got
this food
we kill it out here
ohhh
Over here you can see all of the
different nutcrackers from all the years
so when
there were 2 kids there was just two
nutcrackers so three kids this is the nutcrackers
And this is Adam and this is Gabrielle
and then five
this must be Eva's
Here as we added kids we added nutcrackers
so that is that whole  collection of nutcrackers
so now that Austin
and Melissa have their own house we are thinking
our collection is going to start disappearing
cause they are going to go home with them
Another family tradition
is these pajamas
Every year everybody
can't open their presents from Santa
till they put their Christmas jammies on
so we have got somebody, one of the boys
this year and they just got white
long sleeve shirts
so we thought they were kid of cool
So another family tradition is this
Advent calendar that one of our
Au pairs had made for us and
this year we got to bring it back out cause we have
neighbor kids and so we got to do fun
things and put little treasures in there
so that was a fun one
Do you miss me? Not really
What did you get?
You are not going to see me for like 8 months after this.
That sucks.
Oh wow!
I love you so much
I love you!
Curse my weak arm
I love you
One of these is going to be a car
I don't think so...they are still trying to fix Barbara
I got airpods. I was excited
I was really excited for my headset because
I used to use wired headphones for my computer
and my cats kept eating them so they kept
breaking so I have been using a speaker for the last
two months and it is annoying because
I don't want people listening to my conversation
I do like eavesdropping
yeah
Are you trying to tell me something? I am trying to tell you something
actually, completely
You don't like dads clothes?
Well he had some really nice pants and then I see him
pouring concrete in them and I an like
huh?  and then I was like
and now I am like oh!
Santa was feeling frisky this year
I appreciate it
Mom what is the best gift dad
has ever gotten you
my heart necklace
Did dad pick those out?
Dad what is the best gift mom has ever gotten you
oh definitely jeans
No, no for real! What is the best gift?
I just said it
Jeans? oh yeah!
They keep me warm at night
What do you think is the best gift you
have given dad? uh his
Hot chocolate machine
yeah...
when did
you use it? it broke
a couple years